you're making about four five grand
passive income a month how many hours do
you need to work managing those four
properties I know this sounds silly but
like 2 hours a week you might not get
results right away if family don't see
you friends don't see you you have to
make the
sacrifice how much is your first
property how much does it make you a
month now about ,000 a month so you're
one yes away from £1,000 a
month you've done extremely well you're
financially free what's
next the man the myth the legend it is
Kush all the way from Stafford what's
going down brother I'm good thanks
Samuel I want to shake a hand on
Financial Freedom thank you you quit
your job now yeah last month how did it
feel really good yeah it's been a long
time coming um but that Journey was
always going to happen yeah yeah yeah
well I'm I'm I'm I'm really proud of you
you've been a massive asset to the
academy um you've now got four
properties four essays yeah making how
much profit about between 4 and 5,000 a
month profit nice good so taught me
through it then how did you get into
property and I want to pick your brain
CU you got so much knowledge there now
about systemization Power Team Building
hacks tricks I'm just going to pick your
brain we're going to dump it out there
on YouTube for everybody freely but how
did it start for you let's do it yeah so
my background is in project management
and automotive design um I've done that
for the last 10 years straight out of
University but always had the um the
want to create my own business and be my
own B yeah um always been looking at
businesses for sale and what can I start
up also had an interest in property um
but sort of didn't know how to get into
it so I saw you on YouTube the first
video I ever saw of you was you were
talking about whether you should buy a
property in a limited company or not
yeah and I was like okay who's this guy
let me just watch a bit more of your
content booked a crash course in
Birmingham with my mom went to see you
um didn't sign up at that point but then
sort of watched more content yeah you
just gain from the the free information
yeah and then just thought okay a week
later I just I just rang up and and
joined the academy cuz I thought I'm in
right I'm up for this I want to do this
so um yeah that was sort of this time
last year and um it took me about 6
months to get the first deal so it was
it was quite tough because I think the
thing people need to be ready for if
they do this is um you might not get
results straight away yeah so it's like
delayed gratification right
um so yeah but six months in got two
deals at the same time two rental essays
how did that come about then that just
came about so I'd finished all the all
the live training with yourself I was
having Mentor calls I was going on the
masterminds every week and I was seeing
people getting deals and you know making
money and being successful and I thought
I need to do something different so I
just thought well I've got a week let
just get as many viewings as possible
and I got two deals out of it and I
thought I'm keeping them both yeah so
then set up two essays within two weeks
yeah um and it just went from there
really I mean we've never had anybody
ever on the academy that's gone to every
Mastermind every week has graduated
through the academy after 12 months and
has not been financially free it's never
happened yeah so when people are
sometimes saying geez it's been like
three months it's been four months oh my
gosh nothing's happened I'm like look
keep persisting keep showing up there's
a reason that it's a 12 Monon program
and not a 12we program sure there's some
people that go and whoa get load is
really fast and it all seems to happen
to fall together but then other people
it takes a long time and that's just and
that's okay because if it was really
fast and really quick and really easy
everybody would do it that's the reality
and the people that succeed are the
people that persist yeah delayed
gratification as you said yeah cuz when
you when normally when you have a job
you go to work you get paid
or when you set up a business the first
6 months or so is a hard SLO and you're
not seeing anything yeah not getting any
return but then when the return does
come it's huge yeah and it's also just
adding to that it's also like you've got
two jobs because I was working fulltime
at the time in a demanding job and
trying to run this business and set it
up and you know get something off the
ground from nothing so yeah you have to
make the sacrifice and say every spare
minute of my weekend and evening is
going towards this business which sucks
yeah short term your family don't see
you yeah friends don't see you but now
you know it's all worth it so it's that
delayed gratification yeah when did you
realize this is this is working now wow
oh my gosh it's happening um so as soon
as the first essay went live the booking
started coming in I was thinking okay
yeah let's see how you know if this
carries on and it just kind of took off
so first month first month making about
£800 to ,000 profit on the first one
yeah and then learning about the um
little tips and tricks from The
Mastermind that that the guys were
sharing about how to get the longer
bookings how to adjust the advert every
day that kind of thing and you've been
really helpful on the masterminds
because for the first six months you
were listening taking notes but now when
you're on there you're the one that's
giving everybody the hacks and saying
try this try this oh have you done this
and you know that's that's great to see
as well yeah um so these two properties
that you got where where were they first
one was in uh Stafford right and the
second one was in Milton Kings but they
came within like two weeks of each other
wow right and where do you live I was
living in Milt keing at the time and now
now I'm just probably going to move back
to Stafford right yeah be close to the
family now likez I'm free I don't need
to be down there yeah you know so um so
how did you get them what were you doing
different because the first six months
was it because you weren't speaking to
land Lords you weren't trying were you
just learning or was it that you were
trying but you were saying the wrong
thing I think it was um I wasn't putting
enough pressure on myself to okay get as
many viewings as I should have been
doing yeah so I was doing viewings but
they weren't consistent every week right
you know I would get in touch with
landlords and agents but I wasn't
tracking my calls I was probably doing a
dozen a week you think you were doing a
dozen a week you know what I mean yeah
but you don't know if you're not
tracking it yeah and it's I see this
happen time and time again it's so easy
to trick yourself into thinking you're
being productive but when really you're
just busying yourself doing stuff I'm
not saying you were doing that yeah but
a lot of people they're just scrolling
right move yeah they're talking to
people they're networking they're
thinking a lot about it but if you're
not tracking how many LS have I spoke to
this week how many agents have I walked
into how many if you're not tracking
those key pis key performance indicators
those kpis it's you can trick yourself
I'm so busy are you let me look at your
phone history maybe there was a bit of
that I don't know it was just sort of
like okay I'll make make a few calls
I'll message a few L open rent yeah I
won't get anywhere and then the next
week I might not do anything but then
the thing that brought it back to me as
I say going on The Mastermind you see
the people are like we joined at the
same time yeah and they're doing all
this right so I need to be doing more
who was that who was that you thought of
somebody when you said that I'm sure um
there's people there people like tutu uh
sad yeah um Kieran right all these sorts
of people that they all join the same
time the same B the twins every week
doing something you know what I mean so
yeah the twins man killing it yeah
that's that's that's the great thing
positive peer pressure yeah yeah also it
shows you that it's possible yeah if if
other people can do it you can do it and
it robs you of excuses because it's like
well they're doing it you can't blame
you can't blame it doesn't work there's
only one there's only one thing that
doesn't work if it doesn't work and
that's you not working yeah um so did
that give a lot of confidence them when
you got that first deal did it kind of
like make you think jeez this is this is
real this is happening yeah um I always
knew could do it I just needed to push
myself a bit more MH um so I kind of
gave myself the urgency like if I don't
get a deal I was treating it like I
didn't have anywhere to live you know
what I mean like it was it was me I know
what you mean yeah I was like I need
somewhere like right now yeah and then
two came so I was like okay so I not can
work and then after the first two were
there I can use them as leverage when
I'm talking to other landlords so it's
much easier now it is easier isn't it
much easier talk to me then Kush I want
to know what you're saying so when
you're speaking to landlords or agents
how are you finding them and how are you
pitching yeah I'm talking to agents but
all of my deals have come through
landlords okay so do I do still talk to
agents but I like going direct to
landlord mainly through open rent and
Country yeah so normally message them
get them on the phone how do you what
how do you deal with open rent because
often on open rent you get all these
automated long responses like you you
how how are you dealing with that not
all of them are like that I'd say
probably like 30 40% okay but the ones
that are I try and just give them the
detail that they're asked for and then
just say can we have a quick chat I've
got a few questions yeah give my number
and then we have a so you just give them
some key points of what they're asking
for did you tell them on over text that
you're a rent to rent company no you
just act like you're a tenant I don't
mention the word company just because
I've had accounts banned before on open
rent right so you a company no do you
say anything at tool that would
differentiate you from just a tenant
sometimes I say like my you know my
business is looking for property in this
area or something but open m are
sensitive about the word company yeah
nice little hack there from kush yeah so
my business is looking to
rent okay and then and then let's say
Gumtree right let's say you go on
Gumtree you type in Milton ke yeah are
you going for houses or apartments or
both I prefer houses do you why is that
um my customer base is towards
contractors business guests so teams of
people and also relocating families so
all four of my properties are are three
bed houses interesting um and I kind of
don't really want to touch apartment I
think just because um my customer base
is bigger groups of people right also
you've got less issues with houses on
like the headle restrictions for example
exactly yeah CU houses are going to be
freeold probably so there's no head leas
there um okay so I'm Gumtree Milton ke
or on Trent you see a house I want a
grand a month rent which is about
average rent for a house um the adverts
there you just going to what just pick
up the phone or text or what yeah
normally I'll just pick up the phone so
what you saying let's let's let's do
this let's go Samuel speaking I own a
house in STO on Trent what's going on
hey Samuel my name is Kush um just seen
that property in STO on Trent is it
still available uh yes it is yeah oh
that's great um can I ask you a few
questions about that one of course yeah
how can I help so you you've got some
pictures on there are they recent does
that show the recent condition yeah yeah
the pictures on there were taken uh last
week by my wife that's perfect okay and
uh when is this one available it's going
to be available from the 1st of December
that's perfect okay and um in terms of
furniture is there any furniture
included in this uh no it's it's just
the white goods that's about it that's
great okay that suits us um so it
wouldn't be me living there myself it'
be my company that's looking to rent it
um but we're looking for a long term let
um I'd love to come and see it based on
the pictures and sort of explain about
that a bit more to you at the viewing um
I can view Thursday midday or Friday
afternoon 3 p.m. which one's better for
you okay I'm going push back a little
bit here now sorry you say it's it's
you're not going to be living it
yourself it's going to be a company L um
what do you mean company L who's who's
going to be living in the property so
it's my company we have an accommodation
business we're established we have four
properties already across the UK
um our client Bas is contractors and
business guests who are traveling for
work attending their projects in the
local area um as I say love to come and
explain that to you at the viewing um
Thursday would you be yeah I mean would
you be able to send me in over an email
um with a bit more information about
your about who who you are exactly with
with your company details and then I'll
have a little think about it yeah of
course that'd be no problem at all um
but can I ask what would you want to
understand in the email um you know just
you know your company name and and how
long you've been going and and things
like that um yeah we can go through that
um but as I say we've been established
for the last year we've got four
properties we've got more demand than
properties at the moment um and we we
essentially take the property on for a
minimum of three years and um okay we we
take good care of the property it's like
a show home essentially okay so if
that's something that works for you we'd
be happy to come and meet you and
discuss it more yeah okay well yeah I
mean we can we can put a viewing in the
diary and I guess that sounds
interesting by the way I'm am I being
extra difficult or am I being pretty
normal quite normal I am aren't I yeah
and that's the thing if you're starting
out brand new and you don't know what to
say you just yeah you just up you you
feel like you're just getting shut down
yeah yeah but what I'm saying is
actually not it's normal it is normal
yeah so sorry but we'll just continue
yeah so yeah um send me an email over
there and that'll be that'll be good um
you know I could potentially be
interested I'm just I'm just wondering
you know I've had a few people pitch me
about company lets and I'm just a bit
concerned that I'm I'm going to get like
uh the property may be trashed parties
stuff like that that that that's my
biggest concern if I'm honest yeah and
those are good concerns to be fair um
there is a lot of people doing this but
at the same time as I say we're
established we've got properties already
we've got procedes in place and
standards and the property is maintained
to a very high standard you know if
there is any damage that's on us it
doesn't happen to us because we have
good guests staying if it's not kept in
a very high standard our guests don't
come and book with us again again so
it's in our interest to keep your
property in a show home condition at all
times um so you know it valid very valid
questions you have but we'd um talk
about it more at the viewing all right
well let's do a viewing we'll have a
chat and uh I'm not saying yes but you
need sound like a nice guy and and we'll
see how things go I'll drop your I'll
drop your a message over with the
address and I'll see you on Friday
that's great thank you cool so basically
what you did is you just honest in it
yeah about being honest open letting
them know because the thing is Sam
learned it needs to be a win-win for
them as well right some people actually
want to be actively involved in their
property and sort of have a relationship
with the tenant but other people just
want hands off no stress yeah one of my
landlords isn't even in the UK and it
suits them I've had some people that
have said no thanks manage it myself and
just want a family in and and and we'll
say cool congratulations hope it goes
well um or some people have just said oh
no sorry we got we've got a wrong
mortgage or we've got a restriction on
the head leas can't can't do that type
of short stayl agreements and you all
right cool wonderful have yourself a
wonderful day do you have any other
properties you know it's about not
taking it personally yeah do you think
some people are scared to make those
calls definitely I think I was probably
one of them at the start well yeah just
because you feel like oh I'm not getting
anywhere but you have to get through
that at the start especially and what
you need to remember is your one yes a i
yeah how much is your first property how
much is it make you a month now your
first property you secured on a rent to
rent about 1,000 a month so you're one
yes away from £1,000 a month yeah so
rather than thinking oh I got a no oh I
got a no you just got to think man I'm
going to keep going till I get some
yeses yeah two deals Financial Freedom
you've got four deals you're making
about four five grand a month yeah on
average is that more than covered your
old job oh yeah how's it feel great man
how many hours do you need to work I
know you probably continually trying to
scout the business and get new
properties but how many hours do you
work managing those four properties I
know this sounds silly but like 2 hours
a
week that does sound silly if that
really yeah how have you systemized it
so good so I've got a channel manager
yeah who do you use I'm with a Vivo and
how do you find a Vivo it's okay um
there are it's not perfect but I've not
used anything else so I can't really
compare it I quite like it either yeah
it's okay once it's set up I I quite
like it I think that there got good
features and I sometimes hear people
complaining about a Vivo um I mean
there's multiple different Channel
managers that's right but personally I'm
team of Evo yeah but yeah they're not
perfect I mean it works okay for me um
but yeah have a good Channel what do
they do then what do rvo do for you so
they'll basically have your um have your
listing and share it to all these online
travel agencies yeah so you create the
um listing in a Vivo in the um sort of
software and they'll send it out to
Airbnb booking.com Google and then your
list is all over the Internet for people
to book they'll also give you a direct
booking link um so if so what's happened
with me is I'll ring every guest before
they check in I'll understand why
they're staying with me uh the reason
for visiting the area and then I'll get
a direct um contact for them I'll get
their they might be saying oh I'll come
every other month yeah I need to come
every other month for a week yeah and
that way I can book them in direct next
time yeah and save on commission y so um
they give you all that facility they
also prevent double bookings as well so
if you're listed on Airbnb and
booking.com is so important yeah did you
meet them at the service accommodation
intensive yeah nice how was that program
that was great learn the learning is
great but being around the room of
people who are all doing it as well yeah
so there's so much in that room that
there's so many people doing it in the
room isn't there and being able to get
connections with them yeah that's um
it's the people man you can't beat the
people so that first property you got
then how long did it take you from start
to finish
to getting the keys to it being live and
you've got bookings money coming in that
one took about 3 weeks sure um which is
longer than I wanted it to be but I was
working full-time so it was literally
weekends and evenings yeah you know
painting getting all the furniture yeah
and I found that the list that you have
just it takes a long time for that list
to be marked off you know all the things
youve got to do to get yeah it's never
ending but um no as I say once it was
done in life the bookings kept coming in
so and now it's set up now it's
systemized what was your last deal then
where was that last one was in stoon
Trent how's that going CU that's quite a
working class area isn't it that's good
yeah does it work well good good
bookings yeah pretty much all
contractors um yeah how much rent you
pay how much rent you for the St Trent
one 1,200 and that's three bed house
yeah so that's quite a lot for a three
bed house detached house big Garden big
house yeah and how much do you charge
per night for that um about between
130 160 yeah occupancy right um that's
pretty good go on it's like 95 really
yeah in Stoke yeah how are you finding
these contractors then because that must
be how much is that making you profit
then that stok house that one at the
moment
is about 800 right how are you finding
these
contractors um a lot of the time it's
just like they'll book and then you just
ring them speak to them and then is that
big trick ringing them when theyve
booked I think so yeah yeah I think so
too you can understand you know who they
are where they're working where they're
from yeah how long they're working there
for if they know other people as well
yeah can ask for recommendation I had it
I booked a place in Zimbabwe recently
I'm staying there just for the week and
I go to Zimbabwe all the time and we've
actually got a home in Zimbabwe but
we're going a big family will going out
and bringing the kids all the in-laws
and everything so thought I'll book I'll
book an extra an extra place and the guy
rang me up and he said to me he it's
almost like he's been on our training he
rang me up and he was like hey looking
forward to seeing you you know where you
from what you coming for oh amazing had
an informal chat so did you come often
to Zimbabwe I was like yeah quite
regular I've got a load of family there
oh great okay well let me give you my
link if you want a book out and I
thought man this is this is perfect you
know I mean it's just crazy so now
that's my whereas if they don't call you
know you might go to different places
each time and but if you've got a
contact and you kind of feel like you
know the guy you know the cont you're
going to just have that as your goto
Place yeah you make that relationship
yeah and he's now going to be saving 15%
on booking.com yeah so if I go for a
week and give him a couple grand for the
week which is how much we're paying
which isn't that much I think it's about
300 a night stay for about about a week
but if I pay two grand he's going to
have to pay
booking.com about 15% is it yeah 15 plus
that plus that yeah so that's going to
be a few hundred quid he's going to have
to pay to booking.com for just one
booking yeah
but he's now I B direct now he's going
to save that money yeah and I'll be
getting a small discount so it just it
just makes sense yeah um how do you find
cleaners because you've got properties
in mu ke you got property in Stoke you
got property in um Stafford cleaners um
I've got a good cleaning seam in Milton
ke and then they were able to recommend
other cleaners up north as well um so
really don't have any issues with that
where did you find them through the
academy yeah nice so shout out to sad
yeah is great said's been on win on
Wednesday yeah of course yeah she joined
on your batch yeah does she have a
cleaning company or just recommended she
recommended me some cleaners yeah so I
went with those that's another thing
about being on the academy is like being
able to just tap into other people's
Network cleaners team accounts lists
it's just makes so much sense yeah and
it's that WhatsApp group is great oh
yeah you put a question in there and you
get so many people message you back yeah
it's brilliant yeah so where are you
going from here then you're financially
free you're making about four five grand
passive income a month You' quit your
job yeah what's next so I'm kind of
pivoting towards BR now y So the plan is
to do at least one brr next year cool um
starting talk now um as was we spoke
about during acpp a few weeks ago yeah
um your advice was to start looking now
so um got brr viewings around
Staffordshire at the moment um but at
the same time if I see good sa deals I'm
going to take them on because I know the
recipe now I know how it works of course
um and it's just I know each one will
bring about a thousand a month so yeah
if they're there I'll take them
absolutely how's it been transitioning
like how did your family and everybody
feel like what was that going on what
was the dynamy there yeah family been
great really supportive they've been in
business all their lives so they
understand it they understand the
motivation they've been helping with the
staging as well which has been great
everyone's been getting involved um and
yeah they're very happy now you know
they can see the the results that 12
work 12 months hard work is paid off
yeah and your wife's happy she's good
yeah well your wife and my wife are
having coffee right now as we speak wife
to be we're not married yet oh sorry
okay okay yeah are you getting married
next year yeah oh mate that's awesome
yeah thank you um but now she's been
great as well helping out with the
staging with like picking the colors and
you know the materials and that sort of
stuff I quite like that as well cuz I'm
quite creative for my job having to
design stuff yeah um but yeah everyone's
come together as a family it's nice to
have family support what about like you
were looking at lots of different
businesses before you got into this one
um how does service accommodation as a
business compare to some of the other
things that you was looking at
doing the big plus for service
accommodation is you can put the rules
and procedures in place and make it a
passive income yeah it's it's not
completely passive because at the end of
the day it's still a business you have
to make sure your customers are happy
make sure your adverts are optimized
at what your competition's doing it
depends how you define passive if some
people think passive means doing nothing
but actually the definition of passive
is little to nowh but there's a little
bit of overseeing always there is with
every business yeah it's never going to
be even if you've employed a a a
managing director and you're the
chairman who just sits on back on the
chair still have to attend the boardroom
meetings yeah make sure you know make
some of the decisions nothing's
completely no work at all yeah so um but
yeah I agree with you I think the fact
that you can systemize it the other
thing Sam is the the um barrier to entry
is quite low in terms of cash yeah you
know to get into a rent to say yeah you
need money to furnish it and deposits
and stuff like that but if you were to
go and buy an existing business
depending what it is you're going to
need a lump of cash to put in yeah you
know or the traditional buy to you need
a deposit right so that's the other
benefit I'd say how much money did you
have to put into your property business
like how much did you start with um I
put in around 10,000 across the first
two okay so Furnishing deposits that
sort of thing yeah and some of that
money you'll get back if you like the
deposit for example yeah yeah yeah and
even the furniture presumably if you
bought it used yours yeah exactly yeah
um so that's not too bad yeah uh how did
you justify investing 12,000 into the uh
mentorship on the academy it wasn't
really a hard decision because I knew I
needed the number one the
education two the network of people who
are doing it so as I say the WhatsApp
chat you know asking the questions
having people around that are doing it
and that are more successful than you
having access to them and having access
to yourself and the mentors yeah book a
mentor call whenever I needed yeah a lot
of the times Samuel I'd book a mental
call and i' get an answer for a question
I didn't even ask how' you mean you know
I'd ring up about a deal and I'd be
thinking oh it doesn't really work as a
HMO let's go through the numbers and
then one of the mentors would say well
have you thought about an sa and then
we'll brainstorm it and then okay I've
got a different yeah possibility here
it's like having Expert Eyes yeah over
your business we had a good time at my
house as well those two days yeah at my
house what was that like brilliant um
again with that it was like listening to
everyone else's stories yeah I learned a
lot and their feed you know your
feedback to them helped me as well yeah
even though I wasn't really thinking of
those particular questions yeah yeah CU
yeah when I'm coaching the next person
you might be thinking I had even thought
of that yeah we're talking about how to
save on viit tax or something you're
thinking oh geez that's going to be my
problem next year that's right um but
that was awesome well mate you've done
extremely well and I'm really pleased
and I really appreciate not just your
success but the fact that you help out
other people and and pull other people
up that are newer on the academy what
would be your final words of wisdom to
wrap up the podcast uh believe in
yourself become the person who you
admire uh you can make a change you just
need to believe in yourself um take
action find people who are successful
and just just go for it yeah yeah get
stuck in respect kushk you thanks for
coming on the show if you want to get
started in property I'd love to spend a
full day with you at the property
investors crash course everything I know
about property condensed into one day's
training I'm going to be in Birmingham
London Manchester up and down the
country if you want to get your tickets
they're just1 and I'll leave a link in
the description see you there God
[Music]
bless